there's until dismiss we grew up under
socialism so we were very rebellious we
came to Berlin to rebel to rebel against
our parents and against the system
it was the fire in our bellies that
brought us here the spoil persons here
here abducted Evelyn and Julia table I
grew up in Hungary's capital Budapest
but they always felt a special
connection to Germany their father is
Hungarian but their mother is Bulgarian
and the two met in Dresden and married
in 1963 in East Berlin they even spoke
some German at home in 1989 after
finishing University but before the
Berlin Wall came down
the two sisters moved to West Berlin
they worked in cafes and were amazed by
the cultural diversity it was an
entirely different world to the one
they've grown up in socialist Hungary as
a child in a family of intellectuals it
was unheard of almost revolutionary
to work in a cafe at some point in all
the years I spent doing various things
connected to my course of study I
noticed that what I liked best was
working in the cafe thus far the our
bottom cafe so in 2014
Eveline decided to open a cafe with her
sister Yulia they called it Lola was
here as children the two women lived for
a time in Syria and they enjoy
travelling their curiosity about other
countries together with their Hungarian
roots are reflected in the cafe's menu
these are all that is severe porked by
Loula the focus on hungry at Lola came
naturally hungarians so of course we
have cucumber salad goulash and polo
cinta but that's not all we serve as
essence or one person all that attracts
and we have a hungarian emphasis for
people who enjoy that cuisine but we're
equally european and even global
Cuccia vegan garish no dish is more
hungarian than goulash originally
shepherd's made this hearty stew in iron
pots over an open fire
what's the secret to a perfect goulash
Julia and Evelyn say it's important to
use just as much onion as meat and then
there's the bell peppers although
hungarians have only been using the
vegetables since the 18th century
when it was brought back to Europe from
the Americas for Hungarians goulash is
more of a soup whereas the stew
variation is called pocket another
essential is paprika which Yuya and
Evelyn gets straight from Hungary
goulash has to cook for at least two
hours in Lola was here it's served with
spaetzle noodles and cucumber salad in a
nod to the colors on the Hungarian flag
the best at scepter and also the goulash
the best recipes always come from your
grandmother's and that's the case with
goulash but although we use our
grandmother's recipe everyone makes
goulash slightly differently
our recipe is a conglomeration of around
six different grandma's recipes and
either goulash at at scepter Govardhan
the two sisters live in the Eastern
Berlin district of Kunstler aback they
say the people in that neighborhood are
a cross-section of society they opened
their cafe here because they knew the
area well the cafe is in a former
pharmacy when it closed
uau and evelyn jumped at the chance to
rent the space they say it has a
customer friendly atmosphere the counter
which they made themselves in part from
steel pipes is a real eye-catcher german
comedian otto vodkas dined in lola was
here and left his signature on a wall
but who is Lola Lola is an effective so
Lola is a fictional woman who typifies
Berlin run of course and Pauline a
deathless character in a blue angel was
also named Lola we've never met this
woman she comes and goes and sometimes
she runs and brings us new inspirations
international musicians also regularly
perform in Lola was here
Yura and Evelyn think art and culture go
well with Hungary's national dish
see a stock first in fact a Canadian
phenom percolator you eat [ __ ]